the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right welcome everyone this is 604
six presentation just make sure you're
in the right place
my name is Lindgren one of the ten TAS
for this class we do have a second ta
for this section
I think he's not here right now but
basically Champlain and I will be
switching every other week I want to
remind you how just heads up this
section is recorded for OCW purpose but
I think he is only recording us the TAS
he won't you're not you're not in a
camera ok all right so the only purpose
we are here is to help you learn this
very interesting and also very useful
class so don't hesitate to ask any
questions or give us any feedback like
whether I'm going too fast or too slow
whether you want us to cover something
that's not in the posted schedule or
yeah just I need anything else anything
we can help alright so let's get started
there are two lectures in this week in
the first week focus on divide and
conquer
it is a class of algorithm that usually
involves recursion in an Albertan
description and professor Devadas work
gone through several algorithms
including weighted interval scheduling
and some a bunch of others and he left
several open problems
so we will answer those open questions
in this section and will also show you a
new algorithm and analyze a bunch of
other algorithms so just to remind
everyone what weighted interval
scheduling is in this problem we are
given a bunch of requests each with a
start time and the finish time and our
goal is to find a subset of them that
are compatible meaning they do not
overlap and that have a largest combined
weight okay are we clear
everyone clear about that so easier case
is when the problem is unweighted
meaning that all you can think of every
task has the same weight in that case we
can just solve it using a greedy
algorithm but when the problem becomes
weighted we have to use dynamic
programming or recursion
srini introduced a simple one a basic
version in a class can someone remind us
how that algorithm works any volunteers
mm-hmm
I can't speak Lala we finished mixing so
we find it it's not the game so what's
your name yeah I think the version you
described is for the unweighted case in
a weighted case we just schedule the
earliest the one with the earliest
finish time and then we remove all the
incompatible ones and we keep going like
that softer unweighted version it is the
weighted version we need to use
recursion remember we break the problem
into many subproblems and each one can
potentially be an optimal solution
that's anyone remember that can you give
it a try
bringing some problems which is the best
solution
then we starting
wait what is the name what is your Amy I
mean okay I mean is that let's just try
everyone as our potential first request
okay so if I set if I - if we choose
because the J as our first we get its
weight and then we're going to solve a
subproblem so let me call the original
problem weighted interval scheduling
with all the incoming requests now we
choose J request as our first now we are
left with a sub problem that starts
after request J finishes so I'll write
that as RJ where I define RJ to be the
set of requests where their start time
is later than the finish time of the J's
request k2 re are just to repeat we
choose a request has the potential
potentially the first two requests and
then we look at all the requests that
starts after it and solve a subproblem
of that case then we take a max
of all the candidate we have and that's
going to give us the optimal solution
any question about this algorithm
right so this algorithm run scene and
square
now we're going to try to optimize that
and come up with a better algorithm so
in order to improve anything we first
want to identify the inefficiency in
this algorithm okay so which part in the
algorithm do you think is inefficient or
silly unnecessary go ahead so you
I was saying that we don't need to go
through every of this case yeah
mm-hmm right I think you are definitely
correct so let me just go through what
this algorithm does and it would be more
clear so what this means is I'll choose
my I choose the first request or because
one as my first request then I'm going
to consider only in the requests that
start after one finishes right that only
leaves request to five potentially some
others I did enjoy there okay that's my
first two candidates in that max my
second the candidate is I choose
requested two as my first request then I
have to remove request one because it
starts to worry and then I'm left with
all the remaining requests I'll solve
that subproblem that's candidate 223 I
choose request the three as my first
request and then I have to remove one
and two because they start too early
oh four as well it also starts too early
right before three finishes I've been
following that so we are left with the
remaining requests okay
is it more clear now go ahead
that's actually
great point so what's her name
Andrew Andrew said we can potentially be
solving many repeated subproblems like
this yeah we definitely don't want to do
that and that's actually the core idea
the one crisp idea of dynamic
programming Andrew can you tell me
what's the definition of dynamic
programming don't remember anyone
remember that go ahead exactly so
dynamic programming says we won't break
a problem a problem into subproblems and
stop problem into even more subproblems
but whenever we solve one we should
memorize or just remember its result in
storage somewhere and if you need it
again
we'll just retrieve it without resolving
the problem that's definitely a great
point so we'll we can analyze this the
complexity of this algorithm later
because I want to touch on this more
efficient algorithm first and we'll see
that even after Andrews optimization is
run time is n square so without that
observation if we are solving repeated
subproblems is will be a lot worse than
that
anything yeah go ahead
hmm sorry spell yet he goes floor to
past I get to like both exploring in
mm-hmm okay cool go ahead
oh you same thing
always fine
start a subproblem later
so any of you if you decided you're
taking a certain
everyone that you want to see how
caffeine there
it's always balanced to start later
so that means that
starting any particular point wearing
for the maximum
mm-hmm okay great yeah I think we're on
the same page so when I described the
steps of this algorithm remember the
first other third candidate I choose
this as my first right it makes zero
sense because if I do that I might as
well put in two as well
doesn't hurt right I won't get that
so yeah the idea is that we shouldn't
try every possible W out request as my
first some requests are just better more
suited to be the first to request how we
are going to do that so apparently one
can potentially be the first request 2
can also be but it makes it doesn't make
any sense for any requests come after
that with yeah because there's an
earlier request right so the efficient
algorithm that's first sort them by
their start time we're going to consider
the request that comes early first
I have my entire problem here now I'm
going to ask a question should I include
requests one in my solution or not
that's only two cases so if I do not
select one in my solution what's the
problem
am I left with
any idea if I decide I will not include
one in my solution yeah exactly because
it does there is no conflicts anywhere
I'll solve a subproblem from two to then
if I do decide to put my request one in
a solution I got this wait so what's the
subproblem I'm left with
hmm yeah in this because example is five
correct but more generally
exactly every request that starts after
one finishes okay now suddenly we're not
breaking the original problem into n
subproblems we only have two sub problem
so let me do a recursion tree which is a
powerful tool in analyzing this sort of
things so we start with our original
problem from 1 to N and we have two
subproblems to 2n + R 1 to n this one
will also break them into subproblems so
what is this one
okay I'm I have my subproblem to 2n and
I need to further reply the same trick
mm-hmm
Wis
the max WI
oh sorry sorry sorry these are these are
the two cases either scheduled either I
do not schedule my first or I schedule
it and this is my first request right
now here I'm left with this problem
either I do not schedule it or I
schedule it as my first request so what
is this one
three when thank us now I'm asking the
same question for two and here
I'll have our two to n so on and so
forth now let me point out a big
difference for this out version and for
the basic version so I'm starting with
the request that starts first if I do
not do that
say if here I am asking the question
four five do i schedule five as my first
or not then what happens then these two
branches do not cover all the cases
right because I can potentially schedule
eight but not as my first in the optimal
solution if I'm asking a question for a
random request however if I start with
the first request first meaning it
starts earliest it will either be not
scheduled or it will be scheduled and as
the first because it cannot be the
second request in my solution any
questions about this are with
okay
now this is algorithm let's analyze its
complexity so what's the overall
capacity when we go all the way down
solve the entire original problem any
guesses what do you think
what do you think
go ahead
mm-hmm
five
next interval start start
all right
cool so because the first step is
sorting which is login login now after I
saw everything
the question I need to answer is how
many unique subproblems are there right
in this entire recursion tree so I'm not
going to solve the same problem twice
how many unique problems exist here and
of them like just this left branch okay
all the others will be one of this right
so I can start from button the bottom of
the tree and work my way up and when I
say when I want to go this take this
step
I'll look up the result of this in one
of one of the subproblems I've already
solved so actually the recursion itself
is only oh then it's questions
okay so we need to start with the
request that starts first alright we
need to decide whether we schedule it or
not and then we need to do the same
thing for this request too
if the start early is the request in
this subset we always need to do that
for all the subproblems
so the overall complexity is n log n but
if we only focus on this recursion step
our improvement is actually larger than
that because it went from n square 2 o
them so why is the original algorithm n
squared I think it also has only n
unique subproblems right so do you agree
that the original algorithm is N squared
or do you think it's also all of n just
focus on the recursion step
we solve some stuff
that's
but assuming I do not do that assuming
whenever I solve it once I store the
results somewhere and I directly get it
okay assuming I do that what's the
complexity
go ahead no you think it's all been so
anyone think it is uh N squared because
I think Sweeney said is n square go
ahead
exactly right yeah so here whenever we
go up one step I'm doing constant number
of work I'm just comparing two numbers
and taking a max however in the original
algorithm which is here whenever I want
to go one step up there are n branches
of the tree so my total amount of work
is like one plus two plus three plus and
right every step becomes harder when I
go up and this is n square
and questions about that
okay this is so much for our weighted
interval scheduling I'm going to
transition into the next topic so any
question on this side in general for the
scheduling problem do you have a
question no okay yep now let's turn to a
second topic of this section which is
stressing over Strassen algorithm is a
efficient algorithm for matrix
multiplication and matrix multiplication
is a really useful primitive or it has
applications in almost every area like I
can think of circuits imitation a
simulation climate simulation and
physics basically everything no I
actually had some experience with matrix
multiplication because my undergrad
research was improving matrix algorithms
and actually many matrix algorithms
including like inversion solving
equations they all use multiplication as
a primitive so it actually comes down to
improving matrix multiplication and I
tried very hard to just optimize this
basic matrix multiplication we take a
roll you take a column and then you get
your answer for this spot everyone's
familiar with that right I tried very
hard but it's still 100x slower than the
best algorithm out there so I finally
look it up and I was completely mind
blown when I know that matrix algorithm
complexity is not in cubic it's actually
smaller than that
is this a surprise to anyone expect that
before and are the technique the more
efficient now where the muses is exactly
Strassen algorithm now that we're
talking about divide and conquer you can
guess it must be a divide and conquer
algorithm and so there's anyone have a
idea how to divide the original problem
you want to give us give it a try
so I familiar with tired matrix
multiplication or blocked matrix
multiplication okay
can you tell us what that is
okay so say this is our a and B and we
want to see we can break each matrix
into four parts I'll call this a11 a12
a21 a.22 b11 b12 b21 b22 same thing plus
C now I would like someone to tell me
what is c1 1 in this case
a 1 2 e 2 1 yep and C 1 2 years just
pick up don't be shy this is also my
first section ever in my life teaching a
recitation I'm more nervous than you
guys mmm what do you see 1 2
a 1 1 a 1 2 A 1 2 B 2 2 so the rule is
the same as before matrix multiply n
compute this we take this row this
column and it gives us this right thank
you
I want to be 2-1-1 okay and same thing
z21 we're going to take this row and
this column a21 b11 plus a 2 2 a 2 1 3 2
2 is a 2 1 1 2 plus a 2 2 B 2 2 okay
I need everyone understands this okay
great so now we've broken up the
original problem into several sub
problems we only need to do matrix
multiplication here eight times and each
of this matrix is half in size if the
original word mess in cubic now each
sub-problem is half in cubic then we
have eight of them so the complexity is
still in cubic no improvement at all so
actually to be more precise we should so
to know because we can further break up
these matrices into smaller blocks so to
be precise is the complexity you should
be given by a recursion eight
subproblems each one half the size plus
can anyone tell me what's the merging
complexity once I get all this
ah duh
go ahead
yeah because I'm adding but is it
constant I'm adding these two matrices
yeah for base cases of course constant
okay so maybe I'm not clear about this
what's what's the step problem in this
case is this multiplication operation
okay and so these are the eight
subproblems I will solve after solving
them I need to add them together and
adding two matrices and each is size
half of n the complexity is yeah it's n
square acp n square so to get a precise
complexity we should solve this
recursion but it will end up being the
same thing as this intuition tends cubic
okay so now this is the magic
so Stratton in 1969 came up with this
algorithm
each of these is a two and a half and by
- matrice okay okay so strossen came up
with this algorithm he somehow defined
m12 m77 matrices in this way I can't
provide any intuition because I didn't
came up with this and somehow with those
seven matrices he can reconstruct he can
compute all the four sub matrices in C
it's not very interesting to check it
because the algorithm is definitely
correct but let's just do one of them
okay how about this one so C 2 1 is M 2
plus M 4 M 2 plus M 4 so and to have a 1
to B 1 1 a 2 2 B 1 1 so there's M 4
there's a 2 2 minus V 1 1 so that
cancels out okay so it we are left with
a21 b11 plus 18 to be 2 1 that's the
correct answer
so this is a I guess it's a very clever
algorithm you have to work in that area
for 10 years to come up with this so
that's not our concern
our goal is to analyze this algorithm
what's the complexity of it
so does anyone understand this recursion
and someone tell me what's the recursion
for this part for this Strassen
algorithm we have the original problem
and we have some go ahead
yeah that's absolutely correct everyone
gets this
so what's strossen did is if he came up
with the seven matrices each one
requires only one multiplication so we
have seven subproblems instead of eight
and that's going to give us a benefit
and improve improvement now so the
question now becomes how do I solve this
recursion and given this recursion how
do I know its complexity the same
question there anyone want to give you
the fact
so that's going to be covered in a third
topic what can I do is
which is master theorem
so massive theorem does exactly that
only does is given a recursion a and P
of n over B plus some work for merging
where a and B are constants it directly
tells you what tieran is in some cases
so I'll first write a formula master
theorem has actually has three cases the
first case is FN is order n raised to C
where C is less than log P of a
grandmaster theorem says this complexity
is P de log P of a
second case again is Theta and see what
hey lassie is obvious equal to be away
then it comes complexity is n raised to
C log k plus 1 and you don't necessarily
have to copy them because and just find
them and find it anywhere and the third
case you can imagine it's the other the
only remaining place which is FN is
large is omega n raised to C where C is
greater than log P obey then master
theorem says is complexity of the
complexity of TN is Theta F n so
intuitively if FN is not too much work
then it's basically this recursion what
recursion gives you if FN dominates FN
is the biggest component then TN is
roughly on the order of a turn and
there's a case in the middle
now let's see why that is place I only
cover one place here
so again we are going to do a recursion
tree because that is very useful eating
all the recursion problems so we start
with the problem of size N and we break
them into problem size and over B so on
and so forth what's the size of this sub
problem
so that recursion represents a class of
recursive algorithm every time it breaks
the problem it reduced the problem size
by a factor B so what do I have here go
ahead and over d square so on and so
forth so what is a in this graph three
things up three by a it's just a
branching factor of this tree right I
keep going finally I will reach my base
case so my next question is after how
many levels of recursion will I reach a
base case of size one
that
dog be of
I'll be off okay so because here is in
over B and over B Square next one and of
the cubic so on so forth so for that say
this last level is teeth level then the
problem size is n over B raised to T and
we want that to be a constant so what is
T
plot P of n this is the recursion tree
and we have that FN amount of merging
work to do so here we have to do FN work
right to merge these a results to the
solution of our problem in and we have F
what's the merging work for this level
for this part of the tree this is my
blog a problem size
then there will be right and we have a
of them okay so so on so forth so then
we can we know what is TN let's just
enumerate all the work we have to do on
the first level we have to do FN okay on
the second level a F and of B I'm sorry
n over P and what's the next level we
have how many subproblems speak louder a
square subproblems and each of them is n
over B squared and finally I reach my
last level they are all base cases so I
have a raise to t of them because I
define T to be my depth of the tree and
each of them is T of one okay so that's
here I'm not entirely happy with this
formula because I have this beautiful
pattern here right except for that last
guy it's a add one a and divide one B
blah blah blah so I'm going to change
this T into F can I do that because it's
in total he is the same right
t1 is a constant of 1 is also a constant
then I get my beautiful form where it's
a sum
from I equals 0 the T what's the what
Xena some
go ahead
a raise to I F and over the everyone
does that
now you can roughly see why we have to
be cases so let me deal with the first
case the first case says FN is older and
ways to see right what does that mean it
means this guy here is Sigma a raise to
n then this is what's in my F great to
see okay there should be a order here
but everything has order before it so I
just admit that so it's actually should
be this okay so this because n raised to
C is actually independent of this son I
can pull it out
and what am I left with
is that correct
now this is a sum of geometric sequence
we know how to solve that but we need to
check whether this ratio is greater or
larger than 1 or if it's equal to 1 and
what is this ratio the case tells us so
C is less than log B of a that means if
i be raised to C is less than B raised
to this guy which is a right so we know
our denominator is greater than our is
smaller than our numerator so this is a
increasing sequence right so what we
have is n raised to C then that plane
raise to t minus 1 divided by this this
thing minus 1 but they are all constants
right Oh everyone familiar with the base
formula of geometric sequence ok so
that's what we have
next we have T equals log B of n that
means 3 raised to T is n correct
so then P raise to T is n and we have
raised to C cancel them can't they
cancel out what do we have on make sure
everyone is following
hmm
a basal tea
no question
okay let me do that again okay it's
actually a race to T and then and over
BT nice to see right this one to here oh
is that some of geometric sequence so if
I have 1 plus Q plus Q square plus all
the way to QT is Q P plus 1 I guess what
he I don't remember very well minus 1
then Q minus 1 okay I guess this should
be P plus 1 okay so this what we were
doing
so this is our Q minus 1 and divided by
Q minus 1 they are all constants so I
don't care about them so a ways to raise
to t plus this thing ways to see but we
said that be waste P raise to t is equal
to n so we're just left with a raise to
t and what is T he is log P of then I
can write it as log a of n over log a of
P I mean for me with that that means log
a of n log B of A okay it's one I
flipped them so it so this what is that
that is n
okay all right
are we
not exactly because I have an order here
right so everything is order if you only
care about order P goal then it's fine
but that theorem says theta so you have
to prove it the other way that it's no
less than that okay I'm not going to do
that it's not it's not very hard
next I'm going to apply this theorem to
the two problems we left here so let's
apply master theorem to this recurrence
I think you are still looking at that
side so what is the ABC for for this is
8
please to write and see is
log P of a is three so that's the which
case of the master theorem okay so the
theorem says it should be n raised to
log V of a which is three okay
now what we have here can I invite
someone to do that for me
want to give it a try
go ahead
okay so we have a seven equals two and
just equals two like before and now we
want to see whether C equals two is
Block B of
hey watch 7
ah
we sure that's still the case so hmm we
should just get and walk to us um yeah
exactly
so yeah log - yeah thank you let's give
him a round applause so log 2 of 7 is
definitely greater than 2
why because log 2 of 4 is 2 right so
this happens to be and raise to 2 point
8 0 and many other digits but is less
than in cubic and just for knowledge
purpose this is no longer the best it
was the best when it was proposed and
well researchers in that area has got it
down to n raise to 2 point 3 5 I think
two point three seven first and 2.35 not
following the literature very closely so
maybe it's two point three for now okay
so I should have one more thing to cover
but I think we are running out of time
sorry about that I can post so the last
thing we should do is remember we have
this median finding algorithm where we
have a recurrence which is I think n
over 5 some sitting and then Plus this
and plus some theta N and we want to
solve this recursion but we cannot apply
master theorem apparently it's not the
right form so we have so when master
theorem doesn't apply we have to study
it case-by-case let me see if I have
time to do that
okay I think I probably do
so to solve that case first can someone
tell me what's the definition of theta
we have to go back to the definition to
solve that
what does state I mean even mean
so if I say at the end it's theta n what
do I really mean so it means I can find
some k1 and k2 such that this holds when
n gets sufficiently large okay so now
we're going to do an induction assuming
for all the small n less than capital n
my TN is bounded by this K 2 and K 1
thing okay then my next step is T of
this capital n would be bounded out to
the left right side first will be
bounded by K 2 and 5 cd+
okay - like thing seeing that in a
second term and plus another theta n so
we know that means it's bounded by some
other number
I'll say a two okay that's the
definition of theta n then can I find I
want this to be sorry all of them should
be capital n capital n n I want this to
be smaller than k2 capital n right
because this so let me redo this first
step this is roughly five of k2 plus 7
over 10 K 2 and plus a 2 of n plus a
bunch of constants that I don't care I
want it to be smaller than K 2 of them
can I reach that of course I can't write
if I select the k2 to be greater than
all we have here what is this this is my
over 10 n + 9 over 10 K 2 plus a 2 right
so if I select ok to to be greater than
10 times a 2
is that one following that when and it's
sufficiently large here and should be
bounded by K 2 and right that's my
that's the induction I'm assuming when n
is smaller than capital n I have solved
them so I can use these two and I saw
the next step so there's the other side
which is very similar I'm not going to
go through that all right so that's all
for today and just to quickly recap we
went through the waited in scheduling
weighted interval scheduling and the
stress on our wooden master theorem and
apply a master theorem and that a case
study of a new recursion okay and thanks
everyone for coming